[Music]
any Americans
CPR parcels
oops yesterday addresses
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie big
surprise we got an early stranger thing
season 4 trailer so we'll break it down
they're a couple big Easter eggs in this
and we know a little bit about what's
happening with the season 4 storyline I
will be doing stranger things season 4
videos just like I did for season 3 and
season 2 so if you're new to my channel
be sure to subscribe to get everything
one of the reasons why they're dropping
this so early is because they need to
start production on season 4 because the
kids are aging up so quickly through
within another year or two they're gonna
look like the teenagers so this does
seem like it's going to be one of the
final seasons of the show they might do
season 5 but they just signed a new
first look deal at Netflix with the
duffer brothers to develop other shows
so unless they have a big spin-off of
stranger things planned it sounds like
they're planning on moving away from
stranger things after they're done with
season 4 but as you see this picture of
Hawkins slowly turning into the upside
down and you see the camera pan out a
little bit with that season 4 logo flash
up you see a clock counting down to
midnight with the tones starting to
chime that's a reference to the Doomsday
Clock which is all about countdown to
total annihilation
that was a turn of the guy used a lot
during the Cold War Between the Soviet
Union in the USA obviously in the
context of stranger things it's all
about the final battle between 11:00 in
the mind flayer will their battle tear
apart both dimensions mutually-assured
telekinetic psychic destruction but the
trademark upside down organic material
growing over everything the blue
coloration the tagline implied that the
final battle will take place inside the
upside-down even though we've traveled
there a couple times it 11 got trapped
there between season 1 and season 2
aside from will being trapped in there
for the entirety of season 1 none of the
other characters have spent a really
long period inside the upside down
they've only been in there briefly
that's why will has that weird
connection to the mind flayer so even
though he doesn't have special powers
the way that 11 have special powers even
though technically her powers aren't
working right at the end of the season
I'll address that in a second he does
have sort of this precognition for the
mind flayer coming for them he knows
when it's around or when it's about to
attack and that's really useful when
you're trying to avoid or trying to
fight it but because of that scene at
the end the tag line is also a reference
to Russia field trip because I feel like
we're all on the same page that the
American that the Russian guards are
talking about in come Chaka Russia in
the secret Russian base is hopper he was
a
captured at the end of the season and
that big explosion when everyone
actually thought that he died because
there was no body but apparently the
reason there was no body is because the
Russians captured him when they were
trying to escape there's a lot of
missing time in between that explosion
when you actually see them walking
around looking for bodies and actually
trying to find people the military has
since been down there to inspect but
there is a lot of unaccounted for time
for those Russians to grab hopper and
get away or at least a couple that
survived the explosion the brand-new
white demagogue in that comes out to eat
this Russian prisoner at the end it's
just more confirmation of that because
how would they get a demo gorgon if they
weren't the same Russians from Hawkins
hey listen yeah how big did you say that
demo burger was because if you remember
the Russians were secretly trying to
open their own gate there are many
places around the world where the
barriers between dimensions are weak but
the only people in the world that were
actually successfully able to open a
portal were the people in Hawkins
because of Elevens accident because she
was so much more powerful than the other
psychics that were popping up around the
world so even though it seems like the
doctor and all those people during
season one had this very special program
you had to imagine that the Soviets had
their exact same group of people that
they were testing trying to create their
own version of eleven but they weren't
as successful that was the whole reason
for the Russians to come to Hawkins and
secretly build a star court mall so that
it could be cover for them using the
Hawkins portal so if the kids were gonna
go fight the mind flayer on its home
turf inside the upside down there are
only a couple of places they can use to
get to the upside down one they can go
back to Hawkins like they say we're not
in Hawkins anymore technically they do
have to come back to Hawkins to use the
portal at the Hawkins lab or if some of
them are going to travel to Russia that
11 could try to open the Russian portal
herself they were unsuccessful when they
tried it themselves but they didn't have
eleven eleven only accidentally opened
the portal for the first time when she
was using her power to try and reach
someone that was all the way across the
world in Russia they were trying to use
her to spy on the Soviets so they
actually have already been to Russia on
the TV show it's just that they haven't
used those flashbacks where eleven is
using her mind to reach out to Russia
she might actually be able to see hopper
doing that same trick too as for eleven
losing her powers at the end of the
season that's just
results of them closing the gate between
dimensions she has sort of this weird
link with the mind flayer in the upside
down so I think that the minute that
they open a new portal to the upside
down her powers will just automatically
turn back on and then when they defeat
the mind flayer inevitably at the end of
the season then her powers might
permanently go away talking about Big
Ideas hero's journey 11 will have to
sacrifice something in order to defeat
the mind flayer and usually that means
sacrificing your life but I think the
whole idea of the show it's a little
more hopeful it actually wants 11 to get
the things that she wants for herself
she wants a normal life so what would
she sacrifice she would probably
sacrifice her powers in order to defeat
the mind player so early prediction
they're successful in defeating the mind
player at the end of the season then her
true reward at the end of the season is
getting to live that normal life that
she's always wanted I haven't heard
anything about spin-offs yes they could
drag this out to Season 5 but I don't
know like the kids are just getting so
old look at how much different they look
between season 2 in the two year time
jump that it took to get season 3
episodes when they went on that great
break and they had to sign all those new
deals and pay all this extra money all
the kids got giant pay raises there was
talk of doing seasons three and four
back-to-back to avoid any potential
delays and issues that will require them
to use D aging technology to make the
kids look younger if you saw the it
movie and then in Chapter two they
actually had to do that with some of
those kids they had to DHD kids when
they got to it chapter two because two
years ago by when they started filming
it
so they looked way way older than they
did during it chapter one in the
flashbacks were supposed to be to that
time period so there was always
continuity issues so that's why you try
to move really fast on new seasons when
you have child actors pretty safe bet
that they're gonna drop season 4
episodes fourth of July weekend next
year just like they did this year they
really like that summer holiday weekend
in related Netflix news The Witcher
series with Henry Cavill is premiering
later this year they have not given us a
hard premiere date but the rumor is that
it's going to be around Christmas time
in December so even though New York
Comic Con is coming up they haven't said
whether or not they're gonna drop a new
trailer for that but I will be doing
which er Netflix videos so leave all
your requests in the comments below
while you wait for everything click here
for The Witcher Netflix trailer and
click here for the brand-new Rick
Morty's season for teaser trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]